hey everybody stop what you're doing and
put down the javascript we're going to
talk about how you can level up with the
fundamentals of
web development so who am i i'm colby
feyock
i'm the one hugging bb8 and kylo ren
over there i work on the ux and
front-end side of things at
you can find me pretty much anywhere on
the web like twitter and youtube by just
googling my name as i'm the only one in
the world
so we're gonna start with the story here
we have two people at the beginning of
their career
on the left we have mark he's a jolly
fellow he likes the color red
and we have luke who's mark's brother
he's more of a green kind of guy
both of our friends are switching their
careers and they're going to give coding
a try
so they both try to find a boot camp to
dive right in
first we have mark mark found this cool
boot camp that promises to make you a
javascript ninja
better yet it only takes one month they
make sure they teach you the most
popular frameworks available right now
so this will make you super marketable
then we have luke luke took a little bit
of a different route he found a course
that takes a little bit longer
but he'll know how to build a whole
website with just html and css
he'll also learn some javascript but
they didn't promise any specific
frameworks
both of her friends decide to submit
their resumes for a job at 1up inc
it's a junior front-end dev position
description for both of them is
a near-perfect fit and luckily they both
get a callback for a good code challenge
once they get on the call they find out
that their task is to take this mock-up
and transform it into a website
they'll have about 45 minutes to do this
after they'll talk a little bit about
their work
not too bad right so first up is mark
this was easy for mark he just got out
of a boot camp where he learned how to
use react
and the job posting says that they want
react so it's perfect
and that he'll build the next challenge
with react he can use some css and js
and he recently read about that a bit so
it should be pretty easy to integrate
for a quick win
then we have luke he again decides to
take a little bit of a different route
that website looks pretty simple right
so he thinks he can do it with some
plain old html
layer on a little css and it should do
the trick
so let's compare solutions well mark
didn't get super far he only got the
title
luke seemed to get pretty far it's not
perfect some mismatched colors and
sizes but it's a good start so what
happened to mark
well let's just say that mark didn't
have a great interview first mark tried
to get a react app going
he forgot that he needs to configure a
package manager to actually install
react with npm
all right so moving past that he thinks
he figured it out he was able to quickly
look up an example where he can add some
external scripts to load react
now we can get moving but dang
that can't load in the browser that's
not native javascript
all right so he thinks that he figured
out he includes babel
with that he can add the babel type to
the script tag and he can use some jsx
and now he's in business
but oh man we're still getting an error
let's check the react docs again quick
all right he needs to wrap it and create
element awesome so that should work and
it does
so now we can start getting moving and
build the actual website
so mark adds a setter and it renders
we're making progress but then he
realizes that he needs to also add some
styles to make it look right
he can't install it from npm so he needs
to find an external link again
but oh no by the time he actually found
out a solution he ran out of time
he spent so much time debugging that
setup that he never actually had the
time to build out the site
on the other hand luke broke out his
favorite text editor just like mark did
but instead of trying to deal with the
packages with npm he just started with
some basic html
to create a header he knew he was able
to throw a few html
elements together he used the header and
the nav tags nice and semantic
for the content he added a main tag an
image and some text
figured he can use some css to position
it all correctly
so he did he added some styles to make
it look right he flips flexbox makes
this really nice and easy to do so he
flexed the header flexed
the body content flexbox all the things
and he was good to go
with all that luke ended up with a lot
more progress than mark so of course
luke lands the job he went over why he
chose flexbox he went over why he used
the header and the nav tags
he talked about what he would have done
next in order to fix some of the styling
issues
on the other hand mark was still stuck
at the beginning he didn't have much to
talk about
he was still stuck fumbling around
starting with the project with react
so the truth is this story is only
slightly exaggerated
i didn't use real names or likeness but
this exact situation happens quite often
of course someone super experienced with
react might not have hit those same
roadblocks
but i've personally sat through
interviews watching candidates struggle
through these same types of challenges
and this situation isn't unique to react
to be clear this is pretty much any
javascript framework
this is but job seekers come into an
interview wanting to impress everybody
by using the cool's tools
and i totally don't blame them but they
only set themselves up for a failure
so while every company every candidate
and every interview are each
unique there's a common thread it's easy
to want to learn the new exciting tools
and jump right in
and that's not necessarily even a bad
thing part of why i love what i do is
because this stuff is fun
it's the kind of thing that keeps me
inspired but dealing with an interview
is stressful in the first place
and while not every interview is going
to wind up like that we can set
ourselves up with a good foundation
which will let us have a better
understanding of the tools that we're
working with
so we're going to talk about how you can
level up we're going to talk about why
these things can actually make a
difference and we're going to
learn some cool tricks along the way so
we'll start with html
i would imagine most of us have probably
at least heard of html but what exactly
is it
if you didn't know stands for hypertext
markup language is the essential
building block of all websites
and it has been since probably before
most of us have even heard of html
a lot of us probably don't write have to
write this by hand much anymore given
react and other ui libraries do it for
us
but this is the basic skeleton of a web
page we have our doctype our html tag
and body with a simple h1 we're probably
more familiar with this though
the actual skeleton of our page gets
abstracted away so we define our page by
only the content
so instead of our html and head we might
only see our h1
the cool thing about react and jsx
though is we can really write
any html we want for the most part it's
going to be pretty valid
this isn't groundbreaking but this is
kind of setting the tone for some of the
points ahead
but ultimately this jsx gets compiled
down to html
the same html that we can write by hand
we just now have some tooling that can
provide us with ways to generate it more
efficiently
so that gatsby or an xjs app that you
spun up yeah that's just creating a
bunch of html
so next we'll talk a little bit about
css a lot of us probably know this as
the magic that the web design team
creates
i've actually heard some back-end
developers say that they're afraid to
touch it so what exactly is css
css stands for cascading style sheets we
have a simple example here we're setting
the color to red like mark's outfit
changing the font size and making all
the letters uppercase
and bringing this into react we have a
few options personally i'm still a fan
of writing my css
outside of my javascript i like to
supercharge with sass but i know a lot
of people like to write their css in
their javascript
and there are a ton of libraries out
there to do that
but similar to the html we saw before
this all gets compiled down to our basic
css
regardless of the type of tool we use
whether it's sas or css and js
this is what we ultimately get the only
difference is how it's served
whether it's an external link embedded
or online
so a lot of this might not be new for
people aside from the gasp i heard when
i said that i write my css
outside of my javascript it's important
to understand the foundation and how
these basic things work
like did you know that browsers actually
fix the html for you
this could be really helpful especially
when starting but it also can be pretty
confusing if you don't really understand
what's going on
like here you can't nest a div inside of
a paragraph tag
particularly you can't nest another
block level element inside of a
paragraph
so the browser actually tries to fix
this for us but this actually messes up
our intent here
so we were expecting the div to also be
purple but because the browser fixes it
it pulls that div outside of the
paragraph tag and the paragraph style no
longer cascades
or that in css the vertical padding is
actually relative to the width
ignore the junkiness that i'm trying to
show here with the animation but we can
take advantage of this little quirk
sometimes your best option when creating
with images is to use a background image
but the tricky thing
with that is we can't scale the width
and height easily like we can with an
actual image element
instead what we can do is we can set the
height to zero then we can use the width
divided by the height in percentage form
to set vertical padding so this way no
matter the width the height will always
keep the correct ratio
so what's the point in this that i'm
trying to make while those things are
handy to know
those two things alone won't make you a
better developer but what i'm getting at
is understanding your tooling from a
more fundamental level will help you
level up your game
so how can we do that so the first thing
we can apply this to is sto many of us
have probably heard this in one form of
another but maybe you might not
understand what it is
seo stands for search engine
optimization it can be super complex
with keyword research and strategy
but we're going to focus on the stuff
that we can control as developers so our
goal
ultimately with seo is to present our
content in a way that makes it easy for
search engines like google to understand
most important thing here is the content
but it also includes the tags that you
use to present that and the metadata
that you use to make sure that it looks
right in search
most websites have a healthy mix of
different ways for people to get to
their website
some might be ad traffic other social
media but there's also people trying to
look for something in search engine
who could potentially find your site at
the top of that list this helps bring in
traffic which could help your company
and your website grow
like here my website pulls in the most
traffic from organic search just above
freecodecamp.org
of course my modest blog doesn't get the
most traffic on the internet
but how you create your pages matter for
example if your website is a bunch of
images with no
alt or text anywhere how is google going
to be able to know what your page is
about
so what can we do better well we can try
to be more conscious about the html we
use when we're creating websites
more often than not it doesn't take much
more effort to use a different and more
meaningful tag
one thing you can try to do is maintain
a logical page outline of your website
you shouldn't have every single one of
your titles that's an h1 that's not
really helping anybody
instead use h1 through h6 to organize
your content
similar to what you've seen in maybe
like a book what this will do
is queue search engines to the hierarchy
of your website it's helping to answer
what information belongs under what
title
here we have two examples of an image
tag the top one doesn't have any alt
value at all
but our bottom one has a description of
what's actually happening in the image
what do you think is more likely to show
up in a google search
but providing our all we're helping
google to understand what that image is
it's adding more content value to the
page and ultimately helping us
in our searches somewhat similarly
anchor tags are important for how google
reads your page it might be easy to
tack on a read more link dynamically
after a paragraph but when search
engines crawl your page
they look at the text of the link to try
to find out the context about each of
those links
so using the same text everywhere like
read more isn't really helping
instead we can add links to descriptive
parts of our text where we already have
something
we can make it easier for google to
understand what those links are about
if you go to a website and click around
and you look at the words in the browser
tab does it say the same thing for each
tab
the tag that controls this is the title
tag and it's more important for just
that browser tab
this is also what controls the text that
shows up on google
google's getting smarter at adding more
context about pages but chances are
it's not going to consider your links as
valuable if every page shows the same
exact name of your blog instead of what
that page is actually about
alright so next we'll talk about
accessibility accessibility is
the one of the more meaningful points
here
a good high level summary of what
accessibility is is how usable your
website or app is for all types of
people
this is regardless of any type of
disability so that means can someone
with a seeing disability still use your
website
each of us as developers are responsible
for how our creations are being used
the world health organization estimates
that 15 of the world has some sort of
disability
that's over 1 billion people all right
so now the whole world isn't going to be
using my personal website
but how about those 12 000 people that
visited my website so far this year so
just hypothetically
if 15 of those visits were people with
disabilities
that's still over 1800 people that's a
lot of people
imagine websites for businesses like
e-commerce that make money from their
website or
websites that people need to help them
live those are real people who can't use
your website because no one paid
attention to it
for businesses that's a loss of money
but for people's needs that's a
prescription that they're having trouble
failing
we should all take responsibility for
the work that we create it's just the
right thing to do
so what can we do to help our friends
and neighbors well we can learn about
the different types of disabilities that
people face when using the web
we can try to be more conscious about
the decisions that we make just like seo
more often than not it doesn't take much
more effort if at all to develop with
accessibility in mind
so remember our page outline from before
while optimizing for seo by using proper
semantic html
you're also helping screen readers
understand the hierarchy of the page
as the screen reader is moving down a
page it's able to jump over those
sections so that a person
that might not be interested in
particular content can skip through it
imagine this is going to be really
difficult if every single one of those
headers is an h1
and remember our initial example see a
thread here a lot of times when you
write your html properly you're going to
end up providing value in multiple ways
here if a screen reader lands on one of
our images the person will actually get
to hear what that image is showing
it's just another low effort way to help
everyone experience our websites
lists are also a practical use of html
that's used across the web
but far too often i see code that
logically is a list that
is not using the html list elements next
time you create a navigation for your
app don't use a bunch of divs
use the actual html list elements this
will help assistive technology
actually assist the people using it and
they're not much harder to style
set your list style on your unordered
list to none and you're practically
where you were with a div
buttons are also another important
aspect while you can get by with using a
div
you have to do a lot more to get it to a
place where it becomes usable
and oftentimes when i see people using a
div they don't actually take that into
consideration
with a div you get nothing by default
with a button you
while you typically override it you get
something that actually looks like a
button
you get a css cursor that shows that
it's clickable and you get an html
element that people can use their
keyboard with by tabbing and hitting
enter
and did you know that by default when
nested inside of a form
that it's going to actually submit that
form all on its own this is handy for a
variety of things
like not having to worry about setting
up a specific event handler in order to
submit your phone
the point though is this along with the
rest of the html i went over
isn't much more difficult to use we just
need to be a little bit more conscious
and get in the habit of doing it from
the start
and lastly let's talk about simplicity
so what do i actually mean by simplicity
we don't always need extravagant
solutions to get our code to work the
way that we want it
sometimes there's a simpler way to do
things that we're struggling with with
javascript
this is probably a really exaggerated
example of the padding top solution
hopefully i got the math in there right
don't judge me but it shows the
difference on how
some css can replace all that javascript
logic bonus
at least in this case it's likely to be
more performant and bug-free
now there's absolutely some value from
learning by doing i
preach that all the time if you want to
use a bunch of complex tools to build
your blog that's a great low-risk way to
learn into the tools
i even encourage it it's a way to try
new things and rapidly learn without
worrying about breaking things
i lost kind of the amount of times that
i rebuilt my website over the years
before i currently settled on my
relatively simple one
but from a work perspective whether for
a client or for your company's website
try to think about the solutions in
terms of what it will solve is that
extra javascript worth the additional
load it will take in the browser
how much time am i really going to save
with those tools
so what are some ways that we can keep
things simple
well you don't need to rewrite the html
spec every time you add a new component
more often than not the more javascript
you write means that's the more
javascript that you actually ship
which can impact the performance of an
app use what we already have
it's also a lot less work like here we
have the datalist element where we can
create a really simple autocomplete
feature for an input
you don't need javascript to create a
simple loading animation like you might
see on some of your favorite websites
using some css we can use a gradient in
an animation to create this effect
it's just this small snippet here better
yet having it as a class we can extend
it to any
element we want pretty easily
while sometimes we need to maintain the
state of our components
sometimes we don't if we're only
maintaining that state to style
we can instead use the checked attribute
on our input to change how it looks
here we're simply showing different text
depending on if it's checked or not
using pure css
and if i asked you how many of you would
make this how you would make this text
responsive before actually seeing this
how many of you would jump right into
javascript we can actually do this quite
nicely with using some simple css
here i'm setting the font size of our h1
to 10 viewport width
might look a little choppy on the slides
between saving this out
as a gif and trying to present it but i
promise you it's buttery smooth
the way it scales nice and evenly within
our browser and bonus if it gets too
small
we can set a media query breakpoints and
keep it all inside of our css
and as much as there are some good
practical things about the fundamentals
people are also building some really
awesome things with some simple html and
css
this is important because it reminds us
of how much we can do with what's
already out there
it's important because it helps keep
pushing the boundaries of what we can
actually do with native tools
there's massive work already underway
with css if you haven't heard of houdini
yet you should definitely take a look
and this goes beyond the tools that we
already have i believe that
rs won't be happening if we didn't have
the developers that are constantly
trying to push these tools
so it can be important to have
constraints that promote creativity
where you least expect it
like a trend on codepen to try to come
up with a css only solution using a
single div
it's not just challenging it's fun
most online stores look the same so andy
came up with something a little bit more
creative for some adidas shoes
this is using only a css and html to
create this 3d grid effect
or this pen from lin it's a css only
collector's cabinet
i love all the incredible detail put
into it and you can keep looking around
and find something new like that
pokeball
elad made this coronavirus game you're
able to fight the pandemic by clicking
each virus
there's no javascript in here at all
it's all css elab uses some inputs
similar to some other solutions
but uses css loops create the different
animations
this gives us our virus with the ability
to interact
and i have to include my own right so
admittedly i haven't picked up a codepen
in a while this thing's over six years
old name now but the story goes i was
watching the alien movie
for the first time and i stopped
watching it because the title scene
that's because i ended up spending the
rest of the movie remaking this title
screen
inside of css and i still actually have
yet to watch the movie and rewatch it
but just to clarify i know there's a
little javascript in the bottom there
but that's only to provide the handy
restart button at the bottom
but this was challenging and fun and it
might not be practical for every
scenario i'm not going to be putting
this on all of my websites but i can
apply the things i learned to other work
like the micro interactions and the
delightful animations inside the ui
so now that you have all been inevitably
inspired how can we get back to the
basics and learn some fundamentals
free codecamp is a huge community of
learners who are trying to teach
themselves to code
they have great courses free of course
that starts with responsive
web design it's a great place to begin
if you want to start digging into an
actual course egghead also has a huge
library of lessons and courses
you can learn everything from
accessibility to full-blown apps all the
instructors i've worked with are super
smart and really great at helping others
learn
youtube also has a ton of great material
ready to watch free code camp even has
their own channel with a ton of content
but there are a lot of individual
contributors content creators
like me who are posting amazing stuff
every single day
and similar to youtube twitch has a ton
of great content and it seems like
there's another awesome developers
starting their own streaming channel
every day
you can get a live walkthrough on how to
build some of these things and bonus
you can hop in the chat maybe even ask a
question or two
and codepen i feel like codepen really
changed the game when it comes to css
and javascript proof of concepts it's
incredible what you can
find just by browsing around and it's
not just plain css and html
there's really a ton of advanced
javascript work on there and best of all
you have the code immediately available
that you can fork and start playing
around with yourself
so how are you feeling after all that i
really hope inspired
there's a lot you can learn without
diving head first into javascript
if you take all these things into
consideration you're going to be better
off as a developer
not only will you help yourself by
avoiding over-engineering solutions
which
can typically bring on more stress but
you're also going to help others bring
more traffic to your
projects and help others use them while
this talk is about the fundamentals if
you're looking for more
opportunities to learn by doing you can
check out my free ebook called 50
projects for react in the static web
which includes 50 project ideas
complete with project briefs layouts and
resources the best way to learn is by
doing
like i said before and this will help
you avoid asking yourself what to build
and just start getting built
building and that's it if you want more
you can find me pretty
much at colby fact if you want more
resources i typically do
weekly tutorials and put out videos to
go with them um and i'll also tweet out
a link with all the stuff
you've seen here today thank you